what is up there reject nation we are here today
to now rank the batman actors the live-action
theatrical versions of them you might have caught
our ranking the batman movies list and within the
time of filming that video i've rewatched some
batman movies and believe it or not this list on
my end might surprise you before we go into that
why don't you guys leave a like let's just swing
into it then shall we john you want to kick us off
sure i would love to uh and the number seven spot
for me is a batman who i thought was actually a
really great casting choice but doesn't really
amount to much more than that and that would be
good old george clooney i feel like there's a
lot about his persona that lends itself very
well to bruce wayne there are aspects of his
performance i do like i feel like he showed up i
just don't necessarily think that he put a unique
character spin on bruce batman beyond his george
clooney charms which lend themselves more to
bruce than batman so that's why he lands in my
bottom spot could not disagree more with you
john george clooney's my number one i'm swirling
it ahead of you guys no i would definitely say
george clooney's like the bottom of the bottom
for everything that you said yes and the main
reason why is because whatever goodwill george
clooney had for this movie it is just completely
overshadowed by all the crap surrounding that
film to the point where i don't know what was good
about george clooney being in this film other than
the fact that it might have sounded good on paper
to this day like an older bruce wayne george
clinton like i could see it it leaves like
no impression it actually comes across as the
most bland to me and makes his performance just
a mockery of batman even though i don't feel like
his intention while filming it was ultimately that
it's kind of just wrapped in a schumacher mess is
the way i would put it i feel we'll be all lined
up until we're at the top three then we'll see
where we're at okay what's your number my number
six is val kilmer for a specific reason because
in re-watching batman forever which landed towards
the very bottom of my batman movie's ranking list
one pleasant surprise out of that was i actually
really like val kilmer as bruce wayne not as
much as batman i feel like when he's batman it's
actually a little distracting or there's something
about him that doesn't really quite match with the
whole persona he's trying to put on as batman but
as bruce wayne i was actually quite endeared to
him and i really like the take that he is really
intent on you know philanthropy he does seem
more like a reclusive and a you know just guy
rather than like hey playboy and i like that take
on him so i thought val kilmer as bruce was
quite nice but you know given sort of all
the other asterisks surrounding that movie
and the fact that i don't love his batman
as much i would put him in this second to last
spot i thought we'd be a line for a little bit
longer i'm surprised my number six is actually
batman forever's valk kilmer uh yeah val kilmer
val kilmer in this it's interesting because when i
was taking a look at some clips again i was trying
to pinpoint what it was about belle kilmer in
this movie that is just not quite working for me
granted i think what he does is a much bigger
leap than george clooney and batman and robin
but i really think this comes down to again the
joel schumacher vision because i feel like val
kilmer is actually doing the best he can do given
the circumstances and that's part of what weirdly
makes some of his batman scenes unintentionally
funny is because he's doing his best to take this
seriously because of the kind of movie it is i
can't take it as serious as the movie wants me to
however the leg up that i would actually weirdly
give on the portrayal of bruce wayne batman
in batman forever versus the two installments
that came before directed by tim burton this
actually feels more about bruce wayne and batman
than those other two films did so in that aspect
like what you were saying about bruce wayne i do
like that we explored a little bit about him he's
rarely going into like therapy sessions this time
around so i like what he was doing as bruce wayne
however his batman i think it's maybe the lips
i think the lips are a little too glossy there's
something about them lips that just makes me
go i can't take this seriously and you you
come across more like a bro dressed as batman
than you do as a serious menacing guy like i
don't believe the crazy dude underneath there the
god the crazy guy that batman has to be underneath
the mask i'm a little afraid that we might divert
sooner than expected because uh my number five
i deliberated hard and i was just like go with
your heart john so my number five is ben affleck
i think he does a really solid portrayal of bruce
wayne and batman i i really like him in that role
i just don't have the same attachment to it
that everybody else does i feel like once we
got to zack snyder's justice league that was
when i was finally like i see what everybody
else sees and i care about this guy to the degree
that everybody else does but given that it took a
long time to get there and it took so much kind
of sifting through these alternate cuts which
isn't really his performance's fault but even in
the bvs ultimate edition i was like i like him
i'm just not like attached in any particular
way and so due to that i think i mean he's
miles better and more well-rounded than a george
clooney or a val kilmer but there are you know
just things about him that don't draw me in
and touch me personally as a viewer as much
but i think he still is a great choice and if he
was to continue beyond the flash movie i would
be thrilled to see that you're going to get a lot
of agreements on that that's all you'd expect i'm
going to make sure to call this video restore
the snyder verse ranking all the batman movies
to make sure you're okay of course now my number
five would be adam west in batman the 166 666 i
think what adam west is doing here ranks above
val kilmer and george clooney simply because
it is intentional that whole comedic performance
that dry deadpan type of delivery he inhabits
the world like he's the perfect batman to
compliment that world of the 60s batman
it's fun when you watch his interviews with people
like robert pattinson and jeffrey wright who are
like i actually grew up on that batman show and i
didn't think it was funny at the time like i took
it serious i thought there were like real stakes
when i watched that i don't know what it's like
to be plucked into that time period and watch that
show i grew up in the 60s i would still think it
was funny or would i take it serious regardless
his version of batman while not my favorite
i think perfectly inhabits what that world is
and it's the best lead you could ask for for
batman in that version absolutely and that segues
perfectly into my next spot because my next spot
would be adam west and i agree with everything
you said and i think also too looking at his
portrayal of bruce wayne and batman i mean there
is a quirkiness there obviously that is straight
out of that 60s serial vibe but there's something
about the way that he's able to pin that together
like the further we get into these adaptations
the more we explore the sort of interplay between
bruce and batman and the more we explore the idea
that he's probably not like a well-adjusted guy
who just wants to help people he's probably got
a lot of trauma but adam west i feel like plays
that version just this guy who's an eccentric
billionaire who goes out in gallivants and fights
cry like i believe that in some ways more than any
of the other ones going for that kind of a vibe
he's not the most tortured batman because that's
not what they're going for and yet i think he does
a really nice job and i just love watching
him that's the thing is like i really enjoy
genuinely watching his performances no matter
how silly whatever circumstances might read
nowadays so my number four would actually have to
be michael keaton i really like michael keaton i'm
very excited for his return in the flash movie
especially because of the actor michael keaton
that i grew to love over time like a lot of my
favorite works of michael keaton are not the
batman movies it's a bunch of his other work what
i love so much about what he does in this movie in
particular is that there's a kind of subtlety to
the darkness underneath him because it's not like
the most outlandish performance it's not even
the most emotive performance however what's so
cool about what he does is when he is batman you
can also see that with his version of bruce wayne
there is that thing in those michael keaton eyes
that you want to get nuts version of him you could
feel that there's that bruce wayne version
in there that is crazy there's a crazy guy
underneath there and i love how if you just
pay attention to the movie you can feel that
but it's done in such a subtle way the thing that
really overshadows the whole thing for michael
keaton is in both those movies i don't personally
feel like the character tim burton was most
interested in developing or exploring was batman
it's like you think of batman 89 joker was the
big talk you think of batman returns it's penguin
and catwoman who are the big talk i feel like if
you're gonna talk about batman he should be one of
the big talks and he had two movies and he was he
didn't seem to be the thing in the zeitgeist and
to this day he's not the that's most remembered
upon when you think about those films yeah
absolutely and another good segue because uh
my next spot would be michael keaton for a lot of
the same reasons you mentioned and i do think that
yeah once you get to batman returns especially for
me and you are exploring more of just again that
sort of shared folly you do the sort of shared
psychosis of outcasts and whatnot the shared
struggle of outcasts like there are things about
his character that are further illuminated even
though yeah i feel like the movie kind of wants
to be about way other things than bruce or batman
or his personal struggles but yeah michael keaton
just has so much presence and i love watching him
and for the time he was playing the character
uh you know and originating that more gritty
darker more serious take for the first time in
a big scale you know i think he really has a lot
of presence that supports that even if the movies
themselves are focused on other things yeah it's
fighting you know it's a little dated as fighting
and also just michael keaton's bill does feel
a little too skinny for me i feel kind of like
a guy i don't imagine him working out so three
here's the thing with my top three i did fluctuate
between all three of them when i just think about
it if i were to have a pass here for a second
i would say they're all equal because they
all bring something different to each one of the
roles in their own way but if i have to rank them
here it is um so my number three would have to
be christian bale in the dark knight trilogy
i love his performance one thing that i really
love so much about what christian male has done
with this one is he's able to actually have
like a full character arc he's able to start
off as just bruce wayne traumatized decides i'm
gonna become a symbol for gotham the city i love
and then has this complete hero's journey well by
the time you get to dark knight rises he makes the
ultimate hero sacrifice now you actually have a
rarity in the batman world is a full storyline
that is complete with this three picture deal i
think that christian bale does an excellent job
in each one of them do i think the voice in the
dark knight and the dark knight rises that he
does as batman goes a little overboard yeah i do
and i think partly why i would put him as number
three even though i do think he does an excellent
job and batman begins is still my favorite out of
his three performances i think the voice becomes
a bit of a joke more than just the fact that it's
clear he's doing a voice the duality or segway
shift between bruce wayne and batman i feel like
he's really developed a lot of bruce wayne and
it feels like batman he's putting on an act for
me sometimes whereas it's supposed to be this is
the real bruce wayne when he's batman this is the
epitome of all his rage and anger the darkness
yet it feels like he's still doing a performance
as him in those last two films a lot of the time
granted there are some scenes that are just so
perfect for me like the interrogation scene with
him and joker he is excellent i was just trying
to kind of decipher like why is the voice
thing such a meme why is it so joked about
so much specifically with only his batman
like why him i feel like it might come down
to that even though a lot of the time in the
dark night and the dark knight rises i'm not
that distracted by it but i think it does become
distracting due to that and in reality i might
just be pinpointing it to that only because i'm
trying to justify a reason why it's number three
really it's just the emotional impact christian
bale leaves me with is not the strongest out of
the ones i have for number two and number one
at risk of being foolhardy i guess i would go
number two with christian bale and i almost put
him at number one partly because you do have
that fully arced character or at least you have
all three movies worth to see him grow to see him
you know embody and and you know learn with this
character and you see you know the the journey
that he goes through with the other characters
like him and alfred are some of my favorite you
know just emotional beats of those movies and yeah
what it ultimately does come down to for me anyway
is that there are just other things that are more
interesting or that are you know slightly edging
him out in turn like i think he does a really
great job at holding those movies together and he
does have a lot of presence but there is something
where he's not necessarily the most interesting
person on screen the most interesting character
and i think it gets really really close and i
do definitely connect with and identify with him
well you see i feel like with batman begins he is
that but with the dark knight in dark knight rises
he's becomes the less interesting person there but
i do think his bruce wayne is consistently like
one of the best bruce wayne's ever because of
the many relationships that he has in it so what
i love about those movies is like i think a lot of
the writing and context around his bruce wayne is
really well developed because i think there's like
three different personas that he embodies which
is the fake bruce wayne the real bruce wayne when
he's like with michael kane or morgan freeman and
then there's batman and i think that a lot of the
time what's great about him as a lead is he uses
his performance to elevate the supporting cast
that's a great point and and even now i'm sitting
there going is that enough reason to bump him
yeah because it is like and we've been having
kind of a back and forth trying to figure out
exactly how to put the finger on why and and yeah
like i i think there is something to be said for
that ensemble player who really does provide the
backbone and who does allow the other performers
to shine but two i do agree like his bruce
wayne i think is probably the most fully formed
fleshed out and does really sell the idea of his
adjustment you see him in those early stages where
he comes back and he almost shoots joe chill at
one point like you know i feel like he does embody
some of the grief but also the guy who can clearly
function as a public figure billionaire you know
well i think what they do with his batman though
there are motives about it that i don't agree with
like in dark knight rises how he's just given
up on all this yeah seems like he's a bit of
a weak batman after only a year and a half he's
like a crippled man all of a sudden yeah there
are just qualities that they do to him that i do
become critical of as a batman fan my number two
would actually have to be and after re-watching
the batman four times i can now confidently say
that my number two is actually bet affleck yeah
um there was a time where i would say that a
batfleck is my number one and i've seen like bvs
and zack snyder's justice league multiple times
i love ben affleck's batman part of me still
wishes we could get that solo ben affleck movie
make the batflag movie you know what he does best
out of all all the batman for me personally he
is equally magnetic to me as both bruce wayne and
batman i love his like worn down more blunt gritty
bruce wayne who's just like older and like angrier
and his batman is just this martial arts ferocity
machine who could take out a whole warehouse full
of men with assault rifles you know and i really
do love that and i think his progression too from
bvs into zack snyder's justice league where a lot
of zack snyder's justice league is him sort of
making retribution making amends for who he was
in bvs of wanting to do a hero and do right by
superman for not having believed in him like
there's a lot to his character that i think
is very strong i do like the progression of
his character and i think that in terms of
an equal fitting for bruce wayne and batman
the like like i think you're the best one-two
combo it's definitely ben affleck for me
i would say that christian bales is my favorite
bruce wayne but in terms of like the perfect
one-two piece it is ben affleck's uh for me
yeah i think he's just very compelling as both
of them good call thanks for saving the video i
have a very interesting reason for why i would
say who my number one is by the way oh you mean
our number one our number one power number one
battenson the addison the robert pattinson
batman i and i was sitting here going is it
too soon to declare this is it full hearty to on
the heels of you know multiple screenings in you
know a couple of weeks in the whole you know air
of excitement that everyone's had is it too soon
to say that but the more i've seen it and the more
i've thought about it it's a unique experience for
me with a batman movie because he is perhaps
the most engrossing person on screen like
every choice he makes is fascinating and i love
the idea as much as it seems to upset some people
that he's not billionaire playboy yet i really
liked his more twisted more tortured more emo
kid take on the character because that makes a
lot of sense for what age they put him at and
what point in his batman career their take uh you
know picking up from yeah i think he just brought
such a presence and while a lot of people
don't think that there is much difference
between him and batman i would agree that there
is the probably thinnest line between the two i
still found nuances that are only there when he
is just bruce with alfred versus when he's bruce
alone but as batman versus as batman around other
people whether that be gordon or criminals or
whatever yeah it is a unique experience to have
a batman movie where the first thing everybody
wants to talk about is bruce is batman is that
performance i really think that he just knocked
it out of the park in terms of creating a living
emotionally resonant character who fits you know
everything you associate with being quintessential
comic book batman i would uh i would agree with
all that obviously here's what really dawned
on me on my fourth time of watching this movie
and why i was like you know what i think he is my
favorite batman like batman he's not my i don't
dislike his bruce wayne i completely understand
the choice and i overall enjoy the choice of
having his bruce wayne be the way it is and i
think it works just right for that particular
movie i still think we need a little bit more of
him as bruce wayne before i can officially declare
like i love his bruce his batman though it hit
me in the moment when he's going through uh the
penguins nightclub the iceberg lounge i used
to distinguish kind of the difference between
robert pattinson as bruce wayne robertson
as batman was this was that like when he's
just robert pattinson you just see the boy bruce
wayne just in an adult body which is reclusive and
doesn't want to be around people you know kind
of like that weird brother in wedding crushers
that's kind of what he is but when he was going
through the nightclub i realized oh no that boy is
still there and i think that's what really dawned
on me the fourth time i watched this film is that
he carries the boy in the alleyway throughout that
entire performance that is the day batman was born
was the day his parents died and in that entire
performance when he is in the bat suit he's
just a rageful boy it's the game face yeah he's
the boy with the game like when a boy play it's
like that isolated psychotic little boy who
doesn't know how to really socialize but is
really intelligent really observant and has a
lot of unresolved anger it was like kind of dark
not reclusive non-emotive but can let it all out
through rage picking on the bullies and the bad
guys and stuff getting his revenge like it feels
like just a really intelligent rageful boy who
translates into the dark detective throughout that
film so when watching his performance of like even
how he reacts to the cops and reacts when he feels
like gordon might have betrayed him when he's
caught in the interrogation room he just remains a
boy the whole time and i'm like damn that's batman
there's always a thing there where i feel like
the performers that try to make batman be like
the man like batman's a man and which he is like
physically he's a man he's a billionaire man
but i think what robert pattinson does is he
carries that pain throughout the performance
constantly and he carries that underneath the
suit and through the anger and that's where
you feel the anger comes from and so that's why i
personally would say that he is my favorite batman
well i think every other batman has to some degree
an element of they want you to relish in the bruce
wayne and almost aspire to be certain elements
of bruce wayne whereas robert pattinson's does
not have any of that like you can identify you
can sympathize and are sometimes horrified by
what he's going through but he doesn't have
that quality where you're like but he's also
pretty cool you know yeah you're not gonna see
him cruising down the street in the lamborghini
just yet you know making a joke or whatever and i
like that as well they let that distance be there
between you and him he's like the boy who just
doesn't feel like he belongs or fits in anywhere
who distances himself from people and so that's
why all he knows how to do is instill the feelings
that he feels and just evoke fear and then by
the end of the movie he's learning how to connect
like like a hurt boy exactly yeah it just
gets better every time i watch that movie
specifically what he's doing as a character and i
think that's why having that bruce wayne be that
specific way works because there's not much of a
difference the only difference is when he's not
in the outfit when he's not in the cowl he's not
scary or intimidating but when he is in the cow
he's terrifying because that's what he is
underneath well and when he is under the
cow there is some sense of direction and
some sense of investment whereas when he's
just bruce you get the sense that he doesn't
really care to be alive and that's why his
and that's why riddler too paul danno is also
an angry child who just wants family and love
so yeah i think the performance all around of him
is great because for all the reasons i said and
and more that we've talked about in other videos
as well and it gives you faith that whatever we
see next will be just as rich and will expound
upon the character in meaningful ways yeah all
right guys well thank you so much for being here
that was our batman list catch you guys soon